yeah it does i mean i think the the the
mission behind google news is is really
the same thing that we're trying to do
with web search overall for the the
google mission statement of organizing
the world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful that's
what we're trying to do for news as well
we're just trying to sort of apply that
to every in every single different
language every single country every
single source and ultimately down to
every single story so the the process of
putting together google news they i
think the easiest way to think about it
is in sort of three easy steps of how
you get to google news so first is the
crawl process where we go off and
actually crawl the web looking for for
news information there are technically
it's the same process as web search does
there's a google bot or our crawler that
will go off an index information there
are two key differences though in the
crawling process between how news works
and how web search works one is that
Google News is a closed index versus an
open index for web search and what that
means is for for web search if you put
up a personal blog you you start a
website tomorrow at some point web
search is going to go and pick up that
information and index it google news is
focused just on news sites so it's a
it's a smaller set of sites so it's
we're really just looking for for news
sites so it's it's it's a smaller set of
sources in our index and the second is
the speed with which will crawl it so so
web search has you know hundreds and
millions of different URLs that they're
trying to crawl and for for google news
you know we we have a smaller set of
that but it's also the speed with which
we crawl it has to be much much faster
so web search they'll have a wide
variety of crawl times because if it's a
personal blog maybe you updated once a
month or so you don't need to crawl it
every single second for news since we're
crawling these new sites that speed just
has to be it's a matter of minutes it
really has to be as close to real time
as possible so that's one key difference
instead of the crawl part of it the
second part of this whole clustering
which is again one of the the key
innovations that Krishna applied to news
which is taking all these different
sources and trying to cluster them into
similar
types of storyline so it can be trying
to understand obviously same languages
same editions same topics and those same
story clusters together and then the
ranking part of it is is completely
different from from web search and
you'll hear things when people talk
about Google web search don't hear about
page rank and inbound links and out bad
links and it's really a very different
process that we're trying to do for
Google News so some of the things we're
looking at is is obviously timeliness
that matters for a new site location is
at a local source reporting on a local
story doing original reporting something
else we're going to take a look at as
well as the nature of the source at well
so it's not just you know it's not a
human coming in and saying well this is
a good source or a bad source but rather
looking at a number of different signals
to try and determine you know the
quality of a given source are they
produce an original content you know how
to use respond to the brand is there
such a certain value when they see that
link instead of not just the most clicks
because I've become somewhat
self-fulfilling but rather trying to
discern the users trust for a given
source so those are all things that are
really unique to news as opposed to how
web search works